eigentlich wurde ich vor allen Dingen
dass die Gesetze die da sind die er hart
genug sein könnten umgesetzt werden denn
das werden sie nicht eine dieser immer
wiederkehrenden Schlagzeilen Ulm ein
Mann missbraucht 129 mal ein Kind
zweieinhalb Jahre auf Bewährung und
genau das ist auch so das was oft in
unser Land passiert dass
Kinderschänder Kinder missbrauchen nicht
nur einfach Dutzend nach hundertfach und
eigentlich mit zweieinhalb Jahren auf
Bewährung freigelassen werden oft folgt
dann vielleicht sogar noch nach der
Taten den Morty liegt ja dann gibt's
natürlich höhere Strafen aber es wird
immer wieder und das merkt man toleriert
verharmlos und runter gespielt was das
ganze passiert ich war jetzt gerade in
Österreich weil dann gerade ein sehr
bekannter Schauspieler mit
58.000
digitalen Dateien von Kinderpornografie
erwischt wurde und Österreich ist noch
ein bisschen konservativer wie wir hier
und auch dort na ja hat man nicht so
richtig Einverständnis dafür und ich
sag's klar in Deutschland klar und
deutlich Deutschland und Österreich sind
Paradise für Kinder und deshalb bin ich
untergefahren und wir haben da
protestiert vom Landesgericht weil wir
hoffen der kommt hat an dem Tag krank
gemacht ich war nicht verwundert ist ja
auch oft dass da passiert und dann habe
ich eine Rede gehalten klar sehr klar
und deutlich wahrscheinlich zu deutlich
für Österreich aber sie haben sie
zumindestens gesagt und habe mich
gefragt wieso das so ist und wir haben
und jetzt gleich dazu mit ins
Kinderschutz das hier in Deutschland und
Österreich haben Gesetzesvorschläge die
wir in Deutschland verabschiedet haben
Kinder Sexpuppen verboten Handbuch für
Pädophile eintragungs Führungszeugnis
lebenslang für Lehrer die Kinder
missbraucht haben und Kinder
Kinderpornografie zum Verbrechen gemacht
haben wir den Copy und Pest gegeben ein
paar Parteien keine bis auf einen hat
auf reagiert und hat diesen
Gesetzesentwurf mit eingebracht ja wurde
abgelehnt Stempel magistratstempel
abgelehnt und vom Nationalrat und
Gemeinderat und ein halbes Jahr später
und nur durch den Fall teichmeister und
da wurden überhaupt nicht drüber reden
in Österreich wenn ihr gewesen ist und
jetzt sagt stellt er nee haben ich bin
als Vater total betroffen da müssen was
machen und da habe ich gesagt wo waren
Sie denn vom halben Jahr sind abgelehnt
haben
diesen Kampfsportler ich bin
Kampfsportler ich fordere Sie zum Kampf
im Ring für die Kinderschutz heraus wie
wenn sie können so weiter nichts machen
ich schützen sie endlich die Kinder sie
setzen die Gesetze um das geht nicht nur
für Österreich ja aber warum tue ich das
ich will sensibilisieren ich bin anders
ich bin laut ich bin direkt ich bin
unbequem ja aber wir reden hier von
normal die Zukunft unseres Landes sind
die Kinder und wenn dann sowas sehe und
wir waren gerade bei Berlin Berlin hat
einen Riesenskandal gehabt ein Kändler
Experiment ein nachweislicher
Kinderschänder ein Professor den man hat
der durchgehen lassen hat von 1974 bis
2004 in ein Experiment Kinder aus
schweren Familienverhältnissen oder von
Straße in die Hand mit Unterstützung des
Senats und der Schulen die dann
teilweise mit zuständig waren in die
Hand von Kinderschändern gegeben weil
man damit zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe
geschlagen hat man hat die Kinder von
der Straße bekommen oder nicht aus den
Familien und Kinderschänder sind das ist
der Täter geworden nicht öffentlich
wurden sie bis heute entschädigt nein
wurden die Täter zur Strecke gemacht
nein die Mittäter nein was hat Berlin
gemacht unter Verschluss Sache gestellt
ich schäme mich für unser Bundesland
hier habe ich schäme mich auch dafür
dass eine Gesellschaft immer noch so tut
als wenn es kein Problem gibt und wenn
dann jemand wie ich oder andere laut und
direkt ansprechen dann müsste man lieber
diejenigen diskreditieren oder an
schlecht machen die darüber reden ich
will nur eins ich will dass die Kinder
geschützt werden und mal ganz ehrlich
neuneinhalb Jahre habe ich mich bewiesen
habe mitgemacht wir haben Gesetze
umgesetzt und nicht nur hier sondern in
Österreich und noch mal ich bitte nicht
darum die Kinder zu schützen ich
verlange da rum wir alle haben Kinder
Enkelkinder oder danach passt Kinder wir
sehen sie und noch mal pro Tag werden in
Deutschland 50 Kinder offiziell
missbraucht und inoffiziell mit
Sicherheit drei bis fünfmal höher über
18.000 offizielles Missbrauch Zahlen in
Deutschland und in der Pandemie davor
haben wir gewarnt ist alles noch mal
geschrieben nachweislich wir können mal
nachlesen und trotzdem ist es immer noch
so alle Themen kommen oben warum Kinder
können nicht wählen Kinderzahl keine
Steuern Kindern nutzt der Politik
erstmal wenn sie Kohle bringt und ich
könnte so unerträglich die morale einer
gefällt zeigt sich in denen was Sie für
Ihre Kinder tut hat Dietrich Bonhoeffer
gesagt bevor die scheiß Nazis sein hängt
haben und ich denke mal wir sollten
jetzt langsam mal den Arsch hoch kriegen
und sagen unsere Kinder sind wertvoll
wir haben in der Pandemie bewiesen dass
alles über den Rücken der Kinder
ausgetragen wurde die Kinder haben
Schule haben Wissenslücken und sie sind
weiter der Prellball und ich habe die
Schnauze voll kennt man mich dass ich
das dahin und dafür kämpfig und deshalb
auch meine klare meine Forderung an die
andere Regierung und auch an die wünsch
dir was Regierung von Berlin schützt die
Kinder ich helfe euch gerne dabei und
wenn ihr nicht der Meinung seid ihr
macht weiter mache ich euch weiter so
viel Feuer und dann Arsch dass ihr bald
ja dass euch der dampfen weil aus den
Ohren kommt da könnt ihr euch sicher
sein und Millionen von Menschen stehen
hinter mir und wir werden nicht aufgeben
die Kinder er liegt in die Augen meiner
Kinderserie die heute schon größer sind
da sehe ich einfach das ist unsere
Pflicht ist für meine Kinder für ihre
Kinder das vorzubereiten noch habe Dampf
auf der Brust aber ein paar Jahren nicht
mehr es ist meine Pflicht als Vorbild
als Vater dafür zu sorgen dass die
Kinder von morgen nicht die Opfer sind
die wir jetzt schon haben wir müssen
etwas verändern ich weiß wir schaffen
das ja und nicht nur so sondern wir
schaffen das wenn wir uns einfach ans
Herz fassen und die Kinder in unserem
Land genauso schützen den anderen
Ländern ganz ganz großes emotionales
Thema für Sie Kasten stellen sie
sprechen ja auch mit vielen
Opfern mit den Familien sie wissen was
diesen Kindern zustößt wie die sich
fühlen ja kannst du diese wuts diese
Hilflosigkeit die auch aus dieser Rede
von Carsten Stahl gerade spricht diese
Verzweiflung kannst du die
nachvollziehen passiert zu wenig wird zu
wenig geschaut wird zu wenig Acht
gegeben macht die Politik zu wenig wo
sie sowohl liegst du den Finger da in
die Wunde ich glaube das ist bei dem
Thema Kindesmissbrauch zu in der Tat zu
wenig zu wenig Debatten öffentliche
Debatten gibt und wenn man in Schulen
schaut
auch in Grundschulen und dort mitbekommt
dass es bereits Kinder gegeben hat die
offensichtlich Erfahrung gemacht haben
die man eigentlich niemandem wünscht
auch kein Erwachsenen dann ist das
ja wie soll man sagen also eigentlich
fehlen einem die Worte dafür
fürchterlich ist viel zu milde da werden
ganze Leben eigentlich in jungen Jahren
komplett auf deutsch gesagt versaut und
was können wir tun das ist eine große
Frage ich glaube das ist durchaus
dafür Mechanismen gibt um auch stärker
aufzupassen aber die Pandemie hat
natürlich viele viele Kinder aus einem
öffentlichen Raum nämlich dem Schulraum
zurückgeholt in einen Raum über Monate
indem sie dann dem einen oder dem
anderen komplett hilflos ausgeliefert
waren
die offiziellen Zahlen ist hatte ich
noch vergessen ist in unserer wir haben
in jeder Klasse so sagen wir also da
natürlich auch größeren Klassen ein bis
zwei missbrauchte Kinder mittlerweile
also in jeder Klasse kann man sagen
sitzen maximal schon zwei Kinder
missbraucht wurden das ist ein so großes
Problem und wir reden ja nicht über
Kindesmissbrauch wir reden auch von der
Verharmlosung zum Beispiel bei
teichmeister von Kinderpornografie und
dann geht das los und die sagen das ja
ähm dann ist die Frage wer kümmert sich
eigentlich um die Kinder macht das
Jugendamt natürlich aber dann haben Sie
natürlich auch Lehrer die
darf völlig überfordert sind und jetzt
kommen wir zum nächsten Problem da gibt
es die
speziellen oder auch Sonderschulen nicht
mehr wo solche Kinder ja dann auch eine
viel bessere er Treue Betreuung erfahren
würden nämlich aufs stärker auf Sie
zugeschnitten diese Kinder sind jetzt in
normalen Klassen unterwegs das heißt die
sind in gewisser Weise hilflos die
anderen Schülerinnen und Schüler sind
auch hilflos weil sich der Lehrer
überfordert oft sehr sehr stark mit
diesen ein zwei Kindern in der Klasse
auseinandersetzen muss das heißt sie
haben eigentlich auch wenn wir da beim
Thema dann auch sind wie geht man auch
was schafft man für Räume für diese
Kinder wird auch da eigentlich werden
diese Kinder extrem allein gelassen und
werden jetzt sage ich so soll es nicht
klingen wie ich sage aber auch zu einer
Belastung auch für andere Kinder und das
das kann nicht gut sein
wenn dann die Kinder die dort mehr
Aufmerksamkeit bekommen und die anderen
spüren werden sie oft zu Mobbingopfer
das heißt das ist so ein kleiner
Übergang ja es hat eine Dynamik ja
Wahnsinn ja ich bin immer anders ich bin
immer anders und das ist auch für Kinder
nicht schön wenn man immer im Fokus
steht egal was man macht immer die
sonderstunde mit dem Lehrer nach dem
Unterrichtstag noch mal hat für eine
Stunde zusammenzusitzen man ist immer
was besonderes vielleicht will man das
gar nicht sein vielleicht will man
einfach ganz normal sein aber in einem
in einem Raum mit dem das möglich ist
das heißt wenn er Hilflosigkeit
wegschauen fehlt es uns da auch in der
Gesellschaft an Zivilcourage mehr
Wachsamkeit mehr wenn ich diese Zahlen
höre die Carsten schallkarte gesagt hat
dass es in jeder Kita Gruppe betroffene
Kinder gibt derzeit heißt es einem das
Herz und da sind wir doch auch als
Gesellschaft alle gefragt wir sind
inzwischen eine Angst bestimmte
Gesellschaft aber ich komme darauf
nochmal zurück ihr ich bin nicht so
emotional engagiert wieder Herr Strahl
aber ich habe selbst fünf Kinder und ich
war oft immer wieder dankbar dafür dass
bis hier die meisten sind schon
erwachsen von den Kindern das ist da
keine Fälle von von Missbrauch
Misshandlung und so weiter gab ich
glaube wir haben ein ganz großes Problem
hier
kindesmissbrauch ist nur eines der
sehr schwierigen Themen wir haben eine
Angst vor der populismus-keule in der
öffentlichen Debatte eine riesen Angst
vor der populismuskeule und die kommt
zum Beispiel auch beim Thema
Ausländerkriminalität es ist unheimlich
es gibt Missstände in diesem Land die
kaum einer große ausnahmestahl die kaum
einer anzusprechen waren weil weil die
populismus-keule sofort zurückkommt weil
wir alle wissen dass es Menschen gibt
auf der extrem rechten die sagen
Kinderschänder kastrieren oder
wegsperren also ganz böse sagen ja das
gehört genauso zum Thema beim Thema
Ausländer Kriminalität haben wir das
gleiche deswegen meine ich Angst
bestimmte Gesellschaft für eine haben
eine Angst bestimmte öffentliche Debatte
die deren Teilnehmer nicht mehr in der
Lage sind hat er quasi diesen Problemen
zu werden und deswegen das bringt
eigentlich die Populismus Gefahr das
nämlich dann sich Themen so wir haben ja
vorhin schon mal über Reformstau
gesprochen mit sprechen eigentlich über
lauter Themen heute die mit Reform Stau
mit der mit der Notwendigkeit das was
dass ich was ändert zu tun haben ja und
wir sind leider in der Lage wie Franz
Josef Strauß mal früher gesagt hat in
den 70er 80er Jahren die Dinge müssen
erst viel schlimmer werden bevor sie
besser werden und das ist ein Jammer
weil das wird auf den schwächsten auf
diesen Opfern ausgetragen
Herr plus wir haben gerade gehört Angst
getriebene Gesellschaft wir haben zu
viele Angst und deswegen passiert auch
das jetzt in unserer Gesellschaft ein
ganz vielen Ecken gibt es ja Probleme
auf jeden Fall langfrist nicht nur Seele
auf sondern auch oftmals den Verstand
das ist leider so und bei dem Thema was
hoch emotionales ich kann natürlich sehr
sehr gut nachempfinden diese
Emotionalität da frage ich mich
tatsächlich wo ist denn der Staat der
Staat hat ein genuine ist eine genuine
Aufgabe das ist
sicherheitsversorgung und wenn der Staat
das nicht hinkriegt und der Staat das
nicht schafft dann hat er versagt und
wenn diese Zahlen hören
ein bis zwei Kindern in pro Kita da
dreht mir wirklich den den Marken um und
da frage ich mich neben der
Zivilgesellschaft wichtiger Punkt auch
wo ist denn der Staat wenn man ihn mal
braucht der Staat ist sehr gut in Sachen
Wohlstand Verteilung von
Sozialleistungen hervorragend ähm im
Wahlkampf von Berlin kann man da ganz
viel Tolles entdecken aber auch bei
anderen Wahlkämpfen oder später aber
wenn es um das die Aufgabe geht
Sicherheit für Sicherheit zu sorgen dann
und dann haben sie wiederum recht geht
es dann in die Richtung ja Populismus ja
dann sagen die Leute ja das darfst Du
doch wohl nicht mehr sagen diese
Sprichwort ja doch klar kann man sagen
kommt drauf an was danach halt kommt ne
den neuneinhalb Jahren habe ich ja viele
Gespräche auch mit Politiker geführt ja
und ich weiß jetzt mal die Namen weg da
gab es auf welche die mir gesagt haben
ah Kindes Thema Kindesmissbrauch
Kinderschutz hassen Thema der AFD
aber bitte nicht
ignorieren totschweigen und zu tun als
wenn Sie unsere Kinder nichts wert sind
in Österreich wollen sie in den Kampf
gehen mit dem Kanzler nehammer um
endlich aufmerksam zu machen auf das
Thema was halten Sie für die geeignete
Aktionen hier in Deutschland darauf
Aufmerksamkeit
machen aber ich finde ich finde es
sondern ich bin eine Person ist
öffentlichen Lebens ich habe meinen
Namen mein Ruf genommen und wird mich
diesen Film auch mit aufs Spiel gesetzt
weil du bist ja dafür auch in der Ecke
gedrückt hier und da ich frage mich wo
sind eigentlich die ganzen lauten
berühmten Sportler Musiker und ganz ganz
Idole nein das ist ziemlich genau diese
Angst davor irgendwie unbequem zu sein
warum machen wir nicht mal ein Event von
mir aus warum boxt nicht mal zwei große
Boxer oder egal oder Musiker Musiker für
den Kinderschutz und war ganz effizient
für das Thema gegen Kindesmissbrauch
Gewalt an Kindern die Mobbing und
Kindern nein das ist so hmm guck mal was
nutzt es mir oder ich mache es nur wenn
sie mir nicht schadet wie denkt meine
Sponsoren darüber ich scheiß darauf was
man über mich denkt mir geht's nur eins
wenn ich an diesen grä verstehen und
diese Eltern sehe die ihre Kinder
verloren haben wenn ich im richtszahl
höre wie ein Tim missbraucht und getötet
wurde dann machte was mit mir und macht
mich stinksauer und eins können Sie mir
glauben Liebe Politik einen Neuköllner
jungen stinksauer nackten zu haben da
gibt es Dinge die wollt ihr nicht
seid noch was sagen
emotionales Thema ich würde noch
wirklich sehr gerne weil das mich über
Jahre hinweg und bis heute bestimmt auch
viele andere bewegt dieses das darfst du
nicht sagen dann ist das AFD dann ist
man in der falschen Ecke wenn die AFD
sagt das wasser ist nass ist es dann
plötzlich trocken oder was also das ist
ja unglaublich und es kann auch sein
dass von jemand sogar von der
Linkspartei was gute sagt das ist das
halt nur mal so ähm es geht um die
Inhalte und in Deutschland ist es geht
nicht darum was man sagt sondern es geht
darum wer sagt es und vor allen Dingen
wo sagt man auch nicht vergessen wenn
man in der falschen falschen Moment in
der falschen Veranstaltung was sagt er
gibt sich darum welchen welches Wort man
gesagt hat und wer war da oder wer war
ein Publikum mittlerweile geht ja schon
so weit dass man sagt okay wer hat den
dazugehört oder wem könnte es etwas
nutzen ist es doch völlig egal ob es
einer Partei etwas nutzt oder nicht
nutzt wenn der Inhalt passt und in der
inhaltlich passt ja wenn der Inhalt dann
falsch ist dann kann er sich dann eben
inhaltlich auseinandersetzen aber bitte
nicht auf dieser wirklich guten
ja diese dieses
kontaktschuldigen das ist sowas von
zutiefst Deutsch zutiefst peinlich und
abzulehnen